just more we get started with today's
video I want to thank brilliant for
sponsoring it to support biographic sand
to learn more about brilliance go to
brilliant org slash bio graphics and
sign up for free there's also a link in
the description below hundreds of years
ago if you told someone that one day
human beings would fly through the air
that assumed you were talking about
witchcraft and yet in 1904 the Wright
brothers flew the first successful
airplane one decade later in 1914 Jack
Parsons was born while most boys of his
generation was still fascinated by
airplanes Parsons was already two steps
ahead he dreamed about building the
first rocket ship that would take men to
the moon of course back then this idea
was considered a total fantasy in the
1920s and 30s characters like Buck
Rogers popularized the idea that humans
could explore the expanses of space but
it was purely science fiction flying an
airplane is one thing but no man could
truly go to the moon unless they had
magic powers scientists and engineers
from around the world said that the math
it simply didn't add up and that mankind
would never make it out of the
stratosphere for Jack Parsons the
opinions of all these experts didn't
stop him from trying to make this dream
a reality he studied the chemistry
necessary to create a liquid rocket fuel
that was in fact strong enough to defy
gravity and for good measure he
practiced a bit of magic yep
magic his work would become the basis of
NASA's modern-day space program but his
legacy was tarnished by his involvement
with vehicles instead of being in the
limelight of history the memory of his
accomplishments was pushed aside for
years this is the story of the original
Rocket Man Jack Parsons
[Music]
Jack Parsons parents Ruth Whiteside and
marvel Parsons were originally from
wealthy families in Massachusetts they
moved to Los Angeles together in the
early 1900s in 1914 they gave birth to
the subject of today's video marvel
Whiteside Parsons when he was very young
his parents got a divorce and Ruth
Whiteside called her son Jack instead
Ruth purchased a house on Orange Grove
Avenue in Pasadena California which has
the nickname of millionaire mile because
the streets are lined with mansions
Parsons was a bookworm and he enjoyed
reading sci-fi instead of playing
outside and making friends he was so
fascinated by stories of magic that he
once tried to summon the devil in his
own bedroom
Parsons wanted to grow up to build a
rocket ship so badly he was willing to
do whatever it took even selling his
soul to Satan
nothing happens of course since he later
called this experience a magical fiasco
and he never attempted to do it again in
junior high he did badly in school even
though he had at bright mind growing up
without a father Parsons he was awkward
around other boys and many people
considered him to be effeminate another
boy in his class
Edward Forman was also bullied for
reading science fiction books the two
became close friends and shared the
dream of one day going into space when
they were in high school they
experimented with fireworks and homemade
rockets in the passengers backyard he
was always trying to figure out methods
to make the Rockets go higher into the
air the backyard was full of large
craters made from all of these attempts
indeed he was so hyper focused on this
goal that his grades they continued to
plummet Jack Parsons his mother she sent
him to a boarding school called the
brown military academy in the hopes that
this would straighten him out but it
didn't work he was expelled for blowing
up on a fat dormitory toilets Ruth
Whitesides father
they'd been supporting their lavish
lifestyle so when he passed away in 1931
they had to moved to a much smaller
house Parsons was attending college to
study physics and chemistry at the time
but he had to drop out because his
family could no longer afford the
tuition
the chemistry classes he took in school
were enough for him to find
job as a chemist at the Hercules powder
company which specialized in creating
gunpowder he earns $100 a month which is
more like one thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars a month after modern
inflation and he was also learning
much-needed information about explosive
chemicals he married Helen Northrup in
1935 when he was 21 years old he tried
to save up money for tuition so that he
could transfer his credits to Stanford
University then it was simply too
expensive
[Music]
Jack Parsons he was still really close
with that childhood friend we mentioned
Edward Forman he and Ed attended public
lectures at local universities to learn
from some of the greatest minds in the
Aeronautics industry so there's a
Caltech students named Frank Malina who
introduced them to his thesis adviser
Theodore von Karman he allowed them to
have access to the Guggenheim
aeronautical laboratory which had been
abandoned after the Great Depression
once they had access to the
state-of-the-art equipment they gathered
a team of other graduate students at
Caltech to help them build a rocket
engine as their experiments got bigger
and bigger they had to move out into the
desert to an area known as The Devil's
dam in Pasadena their official name was
the GAO Civ rocket research project but
all around campus they earned the
nickname the Suicide Squad because of
that near-death experiences
experimenting with explosives they
succeeded in building a rocket fuel
assisted takeoff rocket called jato soon
enough the United States Air Force took
notice in this rocket engine the
government hired Jack Parsons and his
friends in order to create the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory or JPL years later
this same laboratory would become the
foundation of NASA Parsons made so much
money at all of this that he was able to
buy a mansion in Pasadena which he named
the parsonage
[Music]
by day Jack Parsons seemed to be a man
of science and logic little did his
friends and family know that he was
leading a double life casting magic
spells at night in the hopes that the
universe would help his dreams come true
he met the magician Aleister Crowley and
became deeply involved with the occult
they believed in a belief system called
Thelema their mantra was do what thou
wilt which was a way of manifesting
their wants and desires into existence
Aleister Crowley had grown up in a
strict Quaker household where his
parents raised him to read the Bible on
a daily basis later in life he was able
to attend Cambridge University where it
became evident that he had a
genius-level IQ he wholly rejected the
teachings of the Bible and focused
instead on secularism however anything
against Christianity was interpreted as
being demonic Crowley fully embraced
this as part of his identity calling
himself the Beast and attempting to
summon powerful demons to come to his
aid from the time Jack Parsons was
experimenting with rockets in his
backyard as a kid the idea that man
could actually go into space was still a
fantasy many people refused to believe
that it could one day be real and while
it's hard for us to imagine now the mere
suggestion that man could reach the moon
was considered to be rather sinful while
Thelma has plenty of spooky and
paranormal elements to their religion
their core belief system was actually
not too far away from many New Age
beliefs and modern day publications like
the secret which calls the concept the
law of attraction practitioners of
Felina did in fact believe in magic but
it wasn't just card tricks and parlor
games they practiced sex magic which is
exactly what it sounds like they believe
that the intense feeling people have
while having an orgasm opens a gate to
the universe they believed that in that
small window of opportunity it is
possible for a human being to perform a
magic spell all they really needed to do
to perform this spell was to focus on
their intention while having sex and
their wish would come true because it
was put out into the universe Jack
Parsons became the leader of his own
group and they would have huge sex magic
orgies at his mansion in Pasadena not
surprisingly Parsons his wife did not
enjoy this sort of life
stomp so she left him he began to have
an affair with his wife's sister Sarah
Northrop Hollister we believed very
strongly in the occult unlike her sister
she actually enjoyed participating in
these orgies and Jack Parsons was just
one of many men in the group that she
would practice sex magic with while it
may not surprise anyone Aleister Crowley
was addicted to sex and multiple orgasms
in one day were no longer enough to
satisfy him he experimented with drugs
and he eventually became addicted to
heroin which was his downfall at one of
Jack Parsons meetings he and Sarah
Hollister metz a science fiction writer
named l ron Hubbard if that name sounds
familiar to you it's because Howard
would go on to found the cult of
Scientology but at this time he was one
of the very few sci-fi writers who were
writing in such detail about the
possibility of sending humans into space
as a hardcore sci-fi nerd Jack Parsons
was thrilled to meet al ron Hubbard and
invited him to join in on their parties
as much as he wanted
Parsons believed that he could summon a
goddess named Babylon she has described
as being the great mother of the earth
and a symbol of sexually liberated women
he asked his followers to participate in
a project called the babylon working he
thought their thrall of these sex magic
rituals the Scarlet woman would come
along to give birth to the moon child
they believed that this child could be
raised to aspire to travel to space
instead of holding on to the comforts of
Earth if they never actually gave birth
to a real baby because they hoped that
this would be more of a symbolic gesture
for future generations of mankind a
Scarlet woman was a symbol of free love
throughout the world so people could
have sex outside of marriage more openly
in a way you could actually say that
this spell actually worked just a few
years later the United States entered
the space race and the entire world
turned on their televisions to watch the
first steps onto the moon in the 1960s
the hippies then spread the free love
movement that Parsons had hoped for
maybe just maybe all of that sex magic
actually ended up working
[Music]
after discovering his ties to the occult
in the late forties Jack Parsons was
fired from his job at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory since he was down on his luck
l ron Hubbard asked Jack Parsons if he
would be interested in partnering in a
boat business in Florida
Parsons gave Hubbard $20,000 to start
the business and Sarah Hollister asked
if she could go to after stealing his
girlfriends and robbing him blind
Parsons realized that it made a terrible
mistake by trusting him at this point l
ron Hubbard did create a successful
boating business but he never paid the
money back Jack Parsons had to go to
court to get his twenty thousand dollars
years later l ron Hubbard would become
the founder of his own religion called
Scientology and he used this boat
business to create his Sea Org he
borrowed much of the same principles
taught by Aleister Crowley and Jack
Parsons about setting intentions and
being the best person you can be
he also mixed in his own fictional ideas
made up in his science fiction novels
even though Sarah Hollister left Jack
Parsons to marry L ron Hubbard there
were plenty of other women in the group
who practically worshipped him he met an
actress and artist named Marjorie
Cameron just like all of his other
intentions he had put his ideas about an
elemental woman out into the universe so
when he met her he believed that they
were soul mates
they were so intensely attracted to one
another when they first met that they
spent two weeks straight making love in
his bedroom he married Cameron in 1946
Marjorie Cameron was more than a tad bit
eccentric she claimed that she had
visions of the coming apocalypse and she
created artwork about her occult beliefs
that would later become popular during
The Beat Generation the 1950s was the
beginning of the McCarthy era where the
FBI was investigating anyone under
suspicion of having ties to the
Communist Party they they had to
investigate Jack Parsons due to the fact
that he took documents item from his new
employer Hughes Aircraft Company they
suspected that he may be supplying the
USSR with these documents about rocket
engines after learning he was under
investigation Jack Parsons voluntarily
showed up at the FBI offices in Los
Angeles to explain that he took the
documents home because he wanted to give
examples of his past work to apply to a
job in Israel the FBI at this point
thought that he could actually be a spy
for the Israeli government he was fired
from the Hughes Aircraft Company and
this was enough to
list him from ever getting another
aeronautical drop again declassified
documents reveal that the FBI had been
following Jack Parsons movements since
1948 because of his occult ties to
Aleister Crowley they believed that this
was a subversive group and considered it
to be dangerous they were simply waiting
for a moment where he might have slipped
up in 1951 Parsons career was over and
his marriage to Marjorie Cameron was
falling apart so they separated Jack
Parsons was no longer raking in huge
paychecks he occasionally worked as an
explosives consultants on the sets of
Hollywood action films but these gigs
were few and far between he had to work
the night shift at a gas station and he
rented out the spare rooms in his house
for extra income in June of 1950 to
Parsons received an order from a film
set to create several explosives for a
movie they asked him to hurry because
they were running on a tight schedule
one of his tenants jokes be careful or
you'll blow us all up
Parsons responded with a chuckle and
said that everything would be fine
an hour later they'll have exploded he
was still alive but half of his face had
been blown off from an explosion he was
rushed to the hospital but he died from
his injuries just 37 years old his
official cause of death had been ruled
as an accident but many elements of the
explosion ARP surrounded in mystery he
had so many years of mixing chemicals
and creating bombs people find it hard
to believe that Jack Parsons could have
made such a careless mistake some think
that maybe he was feeling so know that
he wanted to kill himself but if Parsons
intention truly was to commit suicide he
would have known how to build a bomb
that would have killed himself instantly
instead of suffering in the hospital
some people speculate that someone
wanted him dead and they snuck into his
lab to tamper with his chemicals the
idea that he was assassinated by the
government is a conspiracy but it
certainly does make a lot of sense it
seems almost too convenient that Jack
Parsons blew himself up at the start of
the Cold War
he knew plenty of government secrets
about their fledgling space program and
he was already showing signs of wanting
to flee the country
Parsons truly was a genius capable of
building a bigger and better Rawkus than
the ones created by the US government
and they may have feared that he would
sell their services to the USSR the fact
that Jack Parsons credited his work with
the occult for his success in rockets
was an embarrassment the rest of the
aeronautical community if the public
knew about this it would completely ruin
the credibility of the government's
attempts to build a space program they
were already having a hard time raising
taxpayer dollars without some guy
chatting about sex magic
sadly the program earns a lot more
credibility knew once he was out of the
picture after his death NASA would name
one of the craters on the moon after
Jack Parsons only it was on the dark
side this is very much how they felt
about his contribution to rocket science
but they wanted to give credit where
credit is due but many wanted to keep
his memory out of the limelight while he
was alive Jack Parsons ultimate goal was
to have his rocket experiments succeed
not just for himself but for future
generations he wanted the whole world to
look to the Stars and know that it could
be a reality and not just some fantasy
written about in a sci-fi novel whether
you believe in the supernatural or not
in a way Parsons sex magic spells
actually worked because all of his
intentions that he set out into the
universe eventually came true tragically
he did not live long enough to see NASA
send a man to the moon but if he was
watching from across the universe it
would surely be proud and if you want to
learn a bit about the real stuff that
Parsons was interested in a great way to
do that is through brilliance we talked
a lot about rocket science in today's
video and while this is certainly a
complex subject it is one that brilliant
make really easy to get to grips with
the way brilliant works is through
something called active learning and
it's really super effective basically
what this means is that you're not
spending time reading about how
something works looking at complex
equations etc basically going over it
again and again and again until it gets
in your head for me often that's
something that gets just really
frustrating I know a lot of people feel
the same way taking rocket physics as an
example rather than showing you
something really complex and explaining
it it all starts with something super
simple you just have to solve a puzzle
related to the topic it's great to see
how you do a few of these puzzles in
just a few minutes later you find
yourself saying oh so that's what the
side of the equation works it's very
cool and as someone without a background
in science I pretty much started off
thinking yeah guys you're not going to
be able to explain that equation to me
but just a few interactive puzzles later
I'm like oh well now I get it that's
pretty cool it really is just like that
it's kind of a weird way to describe the
prey
I know but that's how it works it's
really interesting how the information
enters your head through this way of
active learning it's a great way to
learn and to support bio graphics and
learn more about brilliance please go to
brilliant dot org slash bio graphics and
sign up for free and also the first 200
people that go through that link will
get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so as always thank you so
much for watching this video do
subscribe for more do check out
brilliance and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]